and hash critically injured after
slamming her car into a home
an update on her condition and new video
taken moments before the fiery crash
kim and p calling it quits i was just
thinking like
heard about this bde i was just
basically dtf
and kanye has entered the chat god sent
me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
chloe and tristan welcome baby number
two
he's a really hands-on dad and so it's
just easy to co-parent with him plus
britney versus k-fed
the pop star fires back after her ex
claims her teenage sons are avoiding
their mom everybody knows i've had a
tough road but
i'm happy where we're at pt's the
download starts right now
sad news in hollywood today as family
friends and co-stars say goodbye to
olivia newton-john the actress singer
and activist died peacefully at her
ranch in southern california this
morning after a decades-long battle with
cancer she was 73.
i had a lot of fears about things and
about dying and i think everyone has
that but i
i'm over that now i mean i've confronted
the worst thing
that can happen now olivia was first
diagnosed with breast cancer in 1992 and
after treatment she lived cancer-free
for a while but more than two decades
later the disease returned this time to
her lower back they're choosing a more
holistic approach she treated the
effects with medical marijuana
i'm very very lucky that i have a
wonderful husband who grows medicinal
cannabis for me that's been helping me
with pain in fact i don't even know if i
have pain because i take it on a regular
basis and i feel very good and i think
it's doing much more for me than just
for pain olivia's lasting legacy
includes grease where she played high
school senior sandy who of course was
hopelessly devoted to john travolta's
danny
[Music]
they had brought up linda ronstadt
they'd brought up marie osmond
and i said
they're wonderful i said but every every
guy in the world wants olivia and john
as
their
girlfriend and john shared his memories
of his co-star today saying you made all
of our lives so much better yours from
the moment i saw you and forever your
danny your john
moving on now to kim kardashian and pete
davidson who have called it quits after
nine months together kim's ex-husband
kanye west is weighing in in the most
kanye way possible the rapper made a
rare return to instagram with this fake
new york times headline reading skeet
davidson dead at age 28. the day comes
days after kim's lawyer told a judge
that the exes were getting along amid
their divorce proceedings with the
source telling e.t kanye is way happier
now that kim and pete have broken up he
never took their relationship seriously
or felt good about pete being around
god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
and pete is letting his clothes do the
talking post breakup in a shirt that
read i feel like ish in australia he's
down under filming his new movie wizards
and apparently distance didn't make the
heart grow fonder a source tells e.t
things were starting to fizzle out now
are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
the pair's romance kicked off with that
kiss last fall when kim hosted saturday
night live the relationship played out
on social media and we got this peek on
the kardashians
pete is has got to be literally the best
human being i've ever met like the best
heart
season two premieres this fall and is
expected to show more of their time as a
couple
babe yeah do you want to shower with me
really quick
we'll likely have to wait for season
three to see exactly how things ended
but our sources say there is no bad
blood telling e.t kim still adores pete
and will always be friends with him but
she wasn't feeling like she was willing
to settle down with him just yet so big
question what's next our source says kim
is ready to be single and date again and
ask for pete my favorite thing ever
which i've yet to achieve is i want to
have a kid
that's like my dream wow now on to kim's
sister khloe kardashian who's officially
a mom of two isn't that crazy the
reality star and her ex tristan thompson
welcomed their second child together a
baby boy via surrogate and this news
came on friday now we're told she's been
with the baby for a while and is so
grateful for a bigger family chloe
tristan also share four-year-old true
who is
so thrilled to have a baby brother now
coco told us three years ago that a
second child was always part of the plan
i never thought i would have only one
child i definitely don't think i would
feel incomplete if i didn't have more
but another one would just add
more love to the house last month our
source said the new baby was a choice
chloe and tristan made together last
november while they were still on good
terms just a month later it was revealed
that he fathered a child with another
woman
everything is
an act of betrayal was tristan going to
tell me if there wasn't a baby involved
absolutely not so is there any chance
for a reconciliation well source told us
last month they don't speak unless
they're co-parenting chloe has moved on
and she's single again the spark she had
with the private equity investor that
kim introduced her to fizzled out a few
weeks ago as for now chloe plans to have
the baby full-time and wants tristan and
both of the kids lives as much as he
wants to be
i see tristan a couple times a week he's
a really hands-on dad we get along
really really well
and so it's just easy to co-parent with
him moving on to anne heisch who's now
in a coma after crashing into a house
causing her car to burst into flames
setting the home on fire
transport the victim
to a hospital
it happened in l.a on friday haish was
taken away on a stretcher and rushed to
the hospital take a look at this ring
camera video of haish allegedly speeding
down a street before slamming into the
two-story home it took crews more than
an hour to put out the flames the woman
who lives in the home was inside but
luckily she wasn't hurt a neighbor says
it was a close call
and the car stopped like two feet away
from where she was sitting so she was
pretty lucky she couldn't get to the
person in the car she told me because of
all the damage the all the things that
collapsed she was stuck sort of in the
back part of the house a rep for haiti
tells et that she suffered burns in the
crash her sled friends are reacting
including her former co-star alec
baldwin my heart goes out to you i'm
sorry that you had this tragic thing
happen to you and i'm sending you all my
love i wonder if she's okay
i think it's a miracle that she didn't
kill anyone listen alcoholics anonymous
works now we don't know yet if alcohol
or drugs were involved but heish has
dealt with substance abuse and mental
health challenges in the past i'm very
open about my life for different reasons
but one is is the to to overcome
difficulties in your life and to
understand that you can get to the other
side of them is is really what my
what my hope is for people who have been
who've been raised in in difficult
circumstances and just three days before
the crash she made an appearance on the
better together podcast where she joked
about downing vodka with wine chasers it
was posted the day of the crash but has
since been taken down it's just [ __ ]
me up so i'm drinking some vodka and
wine
singer amy grant is recovering too after
a bicycle crash last week that left her
unconscious for around 10 minutes and
caused a concussion yeah over the
weekend her husband vince gill took to
took the stage in nashville with their
21 year old daughter karina for this
emotional tribute because
of her accident and everything she's
been going through we've been thinking a
lot about her and
i thought how sweet it would be for her
youngest to sing the song i wrote for
her
[Music]
amy's team tells e.t that she's making
progress every day switching gears now
the gloves are off between britney
spears and her ex-husband kevin
federline in a new interview that aired
on itv kevin claimed their two sons sean
preston and jaden james are choosing not
to see brittany and haven't seen her in
months the former backup dancer added
that the boys made the decision not to
go to her wedding to sam escari because
of suggested photos on her instagram
telling itv news i can't imagine how it
feels to be a teen having to go to high
school who knows how many people ask
them about it it's tough but britt is
not having it now are you sure
in a lengthy instagram message she
called the claims hurtful writing it
saddens me to hear that my ex-husband
has decided to discuss the relationship
between me and my children as we all
know raising teenage boys is never easy
for anyone i love being a mom kevin also
weighed in on britney's conservatorship
battle questioning why the arrangement
lasted so long but showing support for
his former father-in-law jamie spears
saying i saw a man who cared 100
jamie saved her back then but brittany's
new hubby sam has her back he slammed
kevin in an instagram story of his own
ending with a now infamous phrase
directed at the former backup dancer
keep my wife's name out your mouth
people are gonna think what they want
and i mean
they i think
my my character will always show what
type of person i am
now to another newlywed theresa judice
the bravo housewife said i do to louis
ruelas over the weekend in new jersey
[Music]
and it wouldn't be theresa if things
were not over-the-top glamorous i mean
check her out in that gorgeous white
gown and who needs a veil when you got a
crown and hair teased to the heavens she
actually had over 1500 bobby pins in her
head she had over seven thousand dollars
worth of custom luxury hair extension
she was so zen she was so
she was just so ready to the big day was
filmed for an upcoming special with
theresa's four daughters and louie's two
sons there to support them the guest
list also included fellow housewives
margaret joseph cynthia bailey kenya
moore dorinda medley and phaedra parks
and it was one heck of a party
[Music]
noticeably missing teresa's own brother
joe gorga and his wife melissa and
things have gotten ugly yeah source
tells e.t something bad went down when
filming the new season and theresa will
not stop until melissa and joe are
divorced joe melissa were at the jersey
shore during the wedding and our source
goes on to say they have tried for years
to have a relationship with theresa but
are officially done trying it's sad but
the situation is too toxic as for her
ex-husband joe judice a source close to
him tells e.t that he's very happy for
teresa and wishes her all the best
moving on to jacob alerti who is leaning
on some celeb friends while adjusting to
life in the spotlight the euphoria star
covers gq's first ever hype issue
hitting newsstands august 22nd and he
says he saw advice from his deep water
co-star ben affleck after the kissing
booth on netflix made him an overnight
heartthrob he says i had to go through
and delete my high school pictures
because that was the instagram that i
used for my life i wish people could
understand how drastic that change was
and although he's currently one of the
most in demand young actors when he
first got into theater in high school
his friends called him gay and when they
did jacob remembers leaning into the
makeup i started welcoming those kinds
of characters i started welcoming the
femininity and get this jacob recalls
basically living out of his car before
he booked the role of nate jacobs on
euphoria and once he landed it he found
his character inspiration at a gym where
tick tockers work out and while we don't
know much about season three of the hit
hbo show we do know it could be a long
wait
no you might have to wait
10 years
it takes a long time you know no i don't
know i think it's 20 25. i'm not sure
it's nice to take a breath but also you
know it's such a joy being there i could
i could be there for the rest of my life
selena gomez is enjoying her time back
in the spotlight only murders in the
building is nominated for 17 emmys but
there are a few reasons why she totally
gave up her acting career in a new
interview selena who just turned 30
talked about leaving hollywood someday
saying getting married and having kids
would be a game changer i hope to be
married and to be a mom
eventually i'm going to be tired of all
this so i'm probably just gonna devote
most of my life to philanthropy
before i peace out
but don't panic a source told us last
month that selena is not in a serious
relationship right now so she'll be
around for only murder season three
which was greenlit in july well someone
who's not quitting his late night gig
anytime soon jimmy fallon he's closing
out summer with some epic tonight show
guests yeah but in this et exclusive
jimmy told rachel smith he's still
waiting for his crowning moment
is there a guess that you still want to
have on the show we put a word out to
the queen
no really yeah if she wants to play beer
punk whatever
her majesty wants we will do
no luck with her majesty just yet but
the tonight show has plenty of star
power this month demi lovato and meg the
stallion are set to co-host and madonna
is among special guests madonna is a
troublemaker how do you prepare for
someone else's run for the hills
someone else that we absolutely love
seeing on the show
your daughters
hello
they started getting more famous than
these so i go yeah i don't like this so
i took them out of the show and i've
replaced them with acting children oh my
god just better behave than my actual
real children
in addition to late nights jimmy has
another project in the works with
jennifer lopez we both have kids i know
she's a great mom so i go maybe we can
work in a children's book where she goes
yeah that's a good idea let's go that
way jlo could be a guest co-host with
you ben could be in on the act as well
and then why don't you do like a formal
wedding for them you could officiate i'm
sure that's such a great you're welcome
you get on that right you're welcome
we'll get elvis we'll get austin butler
and he could do elvis for you and if
jimmy wasn't busy enough he's also
bringing back the classic game show
password debuting august 9th on nbc jon
hamm came in a little cocky yeah well
john hamm he's so good-looking but when
he comes in i'm like oh my god is there
a mirror
it doesn't seem like that
right let's put your password skills to
the test real quick
news
showbiz
oh my god
it's a harder game than it looks okay
another word um tonight entertainment
on to travis barker who's conquering his
fears one at a time and of course
alongside new wife kourtney kardashian
the rocker posted this video to
instagram of him taking off on a zip
line through the trees with the caption
used to be afraid of heights another
video shows him crossing a razor thin
rope suspension bridge oh that looks fun
good for him the couple seem to be
enjoying the post wedding travels we're
just you know living our best lives and
yeah
the two were also spotted boarding a
commercial flight from l.a to spokane
washington last week according to tmz
now that news comes just weeks after
court's little sis kylie sparked
backlash over her frequent use of a
private jet for short trips now that's
not stopping her from having one epic
mother-daughter date night here she is
with four-year-old stormy at the o2
arena in london for travis scott's first
solo show since the astroworld tragedy
last year
you ready
kylie shared a series of pictures from
the night including a clip of the rapper
celebrating backstage and travis
expressed his love for their support
hopping in the comments section with
these emojis missing from the pics their
little baby boy who was born in february
a store sells e.t things are going super
well for kylie and travis they are doing
fantastic as parents of two travis is
very involved as a father and kylie
loves that speaking of parenting tlc's
smothered is back tonight taking bonding
to a whole new level yeah 18 lauren zema
caught up with the mother-daughter duo
who raised eyebrows last season with
some of their
family activities sexy mama go
if i have this right you've done whole
dancing together well dancing
you did a breast milk facial with cher's
breast milk
anything for the skin and dawn you
shared your lingerie collection with
your daughter to help spice up her
marital sex life why not you know i owe
like share set i have her best interests
at heart and i have some cute lingerie
and we take the same size so why not don
and cher are one of four fan favorite
duos returning on smothered monday on
tlc and season four is kicking it up a
notch one mother-daughter pair takes
baths together another has dated the
same man it's just a little like oops
she's my mom she's my best friend we do
everything alike what else would you do
tease for this season what can the
audiences expect my mom opens her mouth
a lot and you finally you do get to meet
jared's family this season and um their
relationship with my mom and
it's not what you may expect you might
see a physical altercation buckle your
seat belts because this is going to be a
bumpy ride
[Music]
still ahead bad bunny heads back on tour
as other artists dish on their unique
pre-show rituals
[Music]
we do a prayer we do a affirmation uh
trying to spend like
15 minutes a day in an ice in a trash
plus we're taking you inside beyonce's
secret club renaissance in new york
[Music]
et's the download we'll be right back
[Music]
well nicki minaj already has 10 grammy
nominations under her belt but she's
about to be honored in another huge way
mtv just announced she's receiving the
video vanguard award at the vmas on
august 28th she's only the second female
rapper to receive the honor ever after
missy elliott in 2019. nikki is expected
to deliver a career spanning performance
joining these other performers including
anita marshmallow and khalid met panic
at the disco and jay balvin more will be
announced in the coming weeks
jay balvin last performed at the vmas in
2019 with bad bunny who just kicked off
his massive world tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
performed to a sold-out crowd at orlando
florida's camping world stadium the
first stop of bad bunny world's hottest
tour it's been a big week for bad bunny
he stars in bullet train which earned
over 30 million dollars its opening
weekend making it the number one movie
in america not bad for bunny considering
this was his very first movie role not
to mention i mean he got to fight brad
pitt i'm excited this is cool my first
my first movie premiere with brad pitt
you shut down the west side of l.a come
on bro
you said this kind of felt like a
fantasy
how so it is it is i never imagined
before
being here being a red carpet of a
hollywood movie
with a whole
elenco
brad pitt
so i'm very excited i'm enjoying this
moment the concerts are definitely back
in full swing this summer we caught up
with the stars who are dishing on their
pre-show rituals
[Music]
we do a circle circle we do a prayer we
do a affirmation there's a tiny sermon
maybe
i try to spend time in silence and then
warm up stretch i do the same thing but
with a little bit of vodka
[Music]
i usually mix a drink it always starts
with a shot of whiskey for sure even
when i sing at church i take a shot
[Music]
a little tea before a little prayer
before we head out and go on stage
carrie underwood also eats the exact
same thing every show day nut butter
bars for breakfast hummus and veggies
for lunch two scrambled eggs and half an
avocado for dinner while keith urban
gets guitar ready for the stage by
strumming the banjo for wife nicole
kidman
he's trying to stay loose
yeah it's that loose it's like
it looks weird it's weird so weird
bentley hits the bath uh trying to you
know spend like
15 minutes a day in an ice in a trash
can full of ice john legend eats half a
rotisserie chicken as for jesse james
decker i like to have a bone and rib eye
so i like to have a big piece of steak
with a baked potato
and asparagus and i like my steak medium
rare
[Music]
beyonce revealed the vogue in 2013 that
her pre-show ritual includes a prayer a
massage chair and some stretching that's
exactly what i would have needed if i
was invited to bee's secret party over
the weekend the queen reportedly
celebrated her new album which just was
number one on the billboard 200. with a
bash called club renaissance in nyc and
her star-studded guest list rock the
studio 54 theme including kendrick lamar
leo dicaprio donald glover janelle monae
and chloe bailey but it was quest love
with the boots on the ground journalism
sharing this video from inside he also
reported he watched the entire club lose
it when renaissance played from start to
finish three times well you know who
else was losing it lizzo when she got
the news that beyonce spoke her name in
the new break my soul queens remix
featuring madonna lauren hill roberta
fleck tony janet tierra whack
[Applause]
okay
i remember when i was telling my friends
mom what my major in college was gonna
be and i told her i was in a major music
performance and she laughed in my face
she said music performance like beyonce
and laughed in my face only have one
thing to say
[Music]
madonna's celebrating the new track on
tick tock 2 which features a sample of
our 1990 hit vogue and we will leave you
with that actually thanks for watching
guys we'll see you right here tomorrow
for a new episode of et's the download
bye
[Music]